What is the capital of Spain?
o,
its capital is Madrid.
What is the capital of Italy?
Option c,
Rome?
What is the capital of Jamaica?
All right,
it's Kingston.
What is the capital of the Czech Republic?
Its capital is Prague.
Let's continue.
What is the capital of Sweden?
Exactly,
it is painful.
What is the capital of India?
Option b,
New Delhi.
What is the capital of Canada?
Option b,
esotagua.
What is the capital of Egypt?
The answer is a.
Cairo: What is the capital of Indonesia?
Of course,
its capital is.
You are doing very well.
What is the capital of Cameroon?
Option c,
its capital is already a d.
What is the capital of Croatia?
Right,
it's yellow.
Let's go on.
What is the capital of Paraguay?
Option a,
As?
What is the capital of Trinidad and Tobago?
Very well,
its capital is Port of Spain.
What is the capital of Belarus?
Exactly,
it is Minsk.
What is the capital of the Dominican Republic?
Of course,
it is Santo Domingo.
What is the capital of New Zealand?
That is,
its capital is Wellington.
What is the capital of the United Arab Emirates?
The answer is c,
Abu Dhabi.
What is the capital of the Philippines?
Are you right?
Is it Manila?
What is the capital of Chile?
The correct answer is c,
Santiago de Chile.
What is the capital of Jordan?
Its capital is Asman.
What is the capital of Guinea?
,
its capital is Conakry.
What is the capital of Cyprus?
You did very well.
Its capital is Nicosia.